what do you think of when you think
about ninjas in pajamas
beyond the obvious thoughts you have
when you first hear that ridiculous
phrase
csgo fans probably think about an
eternally underachieving team from
sweden
there will be no major in 2017 for nip
aren't gonna be attending the miner
they've been eliminated
nip not making it to the minor once
again the team once cursed by a bay area
witch to only win tournaments in oakland
but once upon a time nip was the best cs
go team in the world
once upon a time nip won 87 maps in a
row
[Music]
87 lan maps in a row is one of the most
impressive esports records of
all time and no team in cs go has really
matched it since
it was just very cool and surprising to
see that you actually can be so dominant
in a game
and also that you were one of the best
players at the same time
that's probably my biggest success it
actually just seems impossible
who could possibly win 87 land maps
without dropping a single one
for comparison cloud 9 the boston major
champions played 16 maps that tournament
and they dropped four of them most teams
that win tournaments drop a
few maps here or there when was the last
time you saw cs go teams win a
tournament without dropping a map
now imagine winning 10. between august
2012 when they won steel serious go
in april 2013 when they placed second at
star ladder star series 5
nip played 10 lan tournaments and didn't
drop a
single map that means nip dominated the
earliest era of competitive cs go
the game came out in august 2012 the
same week nip won their first tournament
nip were the first legendary cs go team
according to esports journalist duncan
thorin shields
they've had a walk going for them at the
time that made that streak possible
for one some of the best counter strike
1.6 teams in the world had
yet to transition to cs goes part of the
reason as to why these teams
didn't change lineups and why they came
over so late to cs go
is because 1.6 didn't actually die when
nip had begun playing cs go when they
placed one on that first tournament cs
go
in august of 2012 there were still a
number of months and a number of 1.6 big
size tournaments
with higher prize purses at times in
first place than cs go csgo had a
messy launch part of it was that the
game was still unbalanced and unrefined
but another part of it was that
dedicated 1.6 players had poured
thousands of hours into their game
cs go just wasn't 1.6
[Music]
so for a while a bunch of pro teams just
kept playing 1.6 there were concurrent
competitive communities for both
cs go and 1.6 and that meant that some
of the best counter-strike players in
the world
just weren't at cs go tournaments esc
didn't enter cs go until september 2012
and were slow to make roster changes
that they would need to become the
dominant forces would be known as as
vertis pro
fnatic and na'vi took longer to enter cs
go but they wouldn't pose a serious
threat for musk
nip on the other hand was going to
tournaments from day one
they were there at the beginning they
had more time with the game and more
time on the maps
and that's an advantage that only gets
mitigated by time but that number
87-0 kind of defies all explanation
some team had to have put in the effort
to beat nip on just
one map some team had to have found the
crack in their armor
but they didn't the only team that held
a candle to nip
was very games the french roster that
went on to become titan
unfortunately back then cs go had a
limited map and that made it even harder
to beat nap
very games chose to focus on four maps
but nip were the best at
all five maps
[Music]
and now it's all on rpk he comes in from
behind to get right position
get right we'll win it for n.i.p gaming
nip's reign finally came to an end at
star ladder star series five
where they lost to virtus pro that was
an all-cis roster featuring the likes of
angel
and dozia here we go shiflaran flashing
over and all the smokes are so good
right now if they can
get in there and put the bomb down it's
all on through flower and he's got it
and he's just going to be waiting to see
if anyone is there and if he decides no
one is so doubt the bomb is going to go
down all but
adrian coming in from behind get right
with the kill adrian with another one
it's a double kill for him
great turn of events adrian with a
triple kill it's all an exist
yes he loses this one round and that's
gonna be it 16-14
vs pro the first team in history to beat
nip on land
they felt quite sad when it happened but
it's like it's
such an amazing run i mean i could never
believe that anything like that would
happen
it was a sign that other teams had begun
to figure out cs go
or at the very least figure out
nationals 1v1 right now he needs the hat
trick
to keep his team in this shock steps
away not gonna happen they are the
winners of the raid call ems one
2013 four finals the record stands as
one of the most impressive in esports
history
and while nip doesn't really live up to
it these days you have to respect the
team built on the foundation of the once
undisputed best cs go team in the world
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button